you've seen this event of privilege
happen you know i've i've sat there we
did this on zoom it was so weird that we
couldn't do this in person but you know
the social
events were happening and
we realized we need to listen we need to
we need to talk there's something going
on here and it's not something going on
it's just there's been a lot that has
not been said
that's always been there yep
um what what is privilege
what does that whole thing mean to you
and how do we how do we deal with it i
mean the correct response is empathy
right um
uh
uh
and the sort of excessive apologizing
like to apologize for how you were born
is a strange reaction but the most
important thing i think is empathy to
try to understand
uh to try and uh
relate
um and we saw this happen
it didn't happen unfortunately because
we don't teach the skills we don't teach
active listening we don't teach
executives or any employee in our
company how to make someone else feel
heard feel understood feel seen
um which is where it starts and if that
can happen then all kinds of trust
builds and and all the other things
start to break away the so for example
when after the murder of george floyd
i was astonished that the number of uh
people in the leadership position
regardless of you know
mid ranking on on up
um
did nothing
you mean in the police force or just in
right no no no no no no in companies
people who lead teams that after the
murder of george floyd they didn't talk
to their teams
they just did nothing and it's not
because they're bad people
it's because they didn't have the skills
they didn't know how to have an
uncomfortable or difficult conversation
and so they chose nothing which makes
things worse
and
uh
and
and and this is just a skill we can
teach people and here's how to have a
difficult conversation you bring your
team together and say
um
we need to have an uncomfortable
conversation
about race and our company
and um
i'm nervous to have this conversation
because i'm afraid that i'm i'm gonna
bumble something
i'm afraid that i'm gonna say something
that will trigger somebody
and i'm afraid i'm gonna say something
or someone will say something that
that may agitate and make this worse but
i think it's more important that we have
this conversation
than we than than my fear of doing this
perfectly
and that's how you start a difficult
conversation
and it is difficult
but it is necessary and those
conversations are not happening
and again not because of bad people it's
because people are afraid and they don't
have the skills to start those
conversations and it is the
responsibility of leaders because that's
why we call you leader we call you
leader because you go first not because
you're in charge but because you go
first first to the unknown first of the
difficult first the dangers
and it is our responsibility as as as
uh
as a corporation
to empower and educate our leaders to to
do the things that they need to do with
their teams
um and um of course up on high same
thing
um
so i think that's where it begins
there's a there's a tremendous lack of
listening in our nation yeah
and a lot of talking a lot of yelling
very little listening